HelloTalk is a platform
that connects language learners all over the world
which makes language learning fun and engaging
My name is Zackery Ngai, founder and CEO of HelloTalk
I was born in Hainan, and grew up in Hong Kong
I have also studied in the United States
and worked in South Korea
Through my multicultural experiences
I founded HelloTalk
I hope every language learner
gets to connect with native speakers
and have real conversations
Since its launch in 2013
it has gained overwhelming popularity among language learners
We have over 12M users globally
and last year we won the award
of Google Play's Best of 2017 for Social Apps
It’s very challenging
to develop a real-time chat app like HelloTalk
Fortunately
we have the Google Play Console to help improve app quality
Android vitals collects and displays data about app performance
including a detailed breakdown by device
This allows quick optimization for target devices
to help improve crash rates and user experience
With Android vitals
HelloTalk has reduced ANR (app not responding) rate by 60%
and excessive wakeups by 95%
HelloTalk has built a stable business model with subscriptions
After adopting Google Play subscription model
we saw an increase of 350% in revenue compared to previous year
HelloTalk’s renewal rate is around 75%
When auto renewal payment fails
users are granted a 7-day grace period to fix payment issues
which improved renewal decline recovery by 13%
We also run introductory pricing offer for potential buyers
our short-term income has also nearly quadrupled
HelloTalk has been a global communications platform since day one
Users can practise over 100 languages
with learning partners from 200 countries
Play Console analytics show us that
retention rates in Japan and South Korea
are much higher than internal average
This provides us with a good reason to invest more in localizing the app
for these two countries - from language to operations
Thanks to Google Play
HelloTalk’s rating in Play Store
has climbed from 3.7 to above 4.3
which strengthens our determination to create better user experiences
through new technology
We sincerely hope that
everyone can master at least 3 languages
while making new friends in different countries
and enjoying the happiness
brought by culture diversity through HelloTalk